so you want to become a data
professional but you don't have a
college degree
and you're not all that interested in
getting one and that's totally fine
let's talk about what a realistic
pathway looks like for you
i'm richard and this is richard on data
so for this one i want to speak about my
own experiences with college so that i
get my own
biases and perspectives out of the way
up front
now i personally went to college myself
in one of the top
universities in the united states and i
got a master's there
so my bachelor's was in statistics and
economics
and my master's was just in statistics
and for the overwhelming most part
the degree was quite useful and helped
me learn
many new ways to think through problems
and there's also no question that
especially in the early stages it helped
to build my career out to where it is
today
having said all of that though i do have
a number of criticisms
first one being that i thought my
program was way too theoretical
and yes i know the theory is quite
important and there's a lot of things in
there that you need to understand
but at least when i experienced it i
think the balance could have been
shifted quite a bit away from the
theoretical and more towards the
application
and the second critique being that
college in general
does sort of require you to take a
number of classes which
aren't necessarily aligned with where
you want to go
but you have to go through these classes
just to meet some kind of
checking the box type of requirements
and that does bring me to some overall
perceptions that i have of college as a
whole
first and foremost being i think being a
degree holder
is held in far higher esteem than it
actually deserves
the degree itself and where you go to
school are not guarantees of your
professional success
nor of being super effective at your
actual job
i know a number of people who came out
of college and
were quite frankly just a little bit
arrogant with respect to their real
capabilities
and particularly if you're going into
your first job you're just
coming out of college but you have no
experience with that particular domain
it's going to be a long time before
you're truly useful
that's going to be true in general
honestly college is not your entire
learning experience
in fact it's just the beginning of it
and while for a lot of people
it is an absolutely wonderful tool i
absolutely do not think that it's the
only way for everyone to become
successful or capable but it's also no
secret whatsoever that there's plenty of
jobs out there
that are absolutely going to require a
college degree
no questions asked having said that
that's not
necessarily the best possible thing that
all of them could be doing in my opinion
anyway
so now that i've said my piece on all
that i'm going to talk about how many
data science specific jobs
really require degrees whether i think
that's necessarily going to be the case
in the future
and then let's say for you getting a
degree or at least an advanced degree
isn't for you
what sorts of things can you be doing
before i do that just some usual asks
number one smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm
number two subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already and hit the bell so
you never miss an update
and then number three i'll have a link
to my patreon account in the description
of the video
if you guys would be willing to support
me over there it would be massively
appreciated
so let's start off with data scientists
and how many of them have degrees
this is taken from the anaconda 2020
state of data science report
now they did a massive global survey and
they found that about
30 percent of respondents held a
bachelor's degree
36 percent held a master's degree 19 or
20 percent had a phd
and then the remaining 15 percent had no
degree
that's most recent and very similar to
other numbers that i've seen
right off the bat we do see about 45
percent of people or so
have a bachelor's degree or less if your
goal anyway is just to avoid getting a
graduate degree
so that's not totally terrible i
couldn't find any similar surveys to
that for data analysts
but it's probably pretty fair to assume
these proportions are pretty similar
over there
just maybe with a slightly smaller
percentage of people probably having
advanced degrees
so now in the interest of fairness i
want to present arguments both
for and against this trend continuing
that is
in the future are more or less jobs
going to require degrees
and then where it makes sense we can
make inferences about the job market as
a whole
and to data analysts and data scientists
specifically
this is an article from cnbc making the
case that the future of work
won't be about degrees but it'll be
about skills
and that's just due to the proliferation
of new and non-traditional
education options this is a perspective
of somebody who's the leader of a tech
company mind you and they list some
companies that don't require a degree
and that includes tech giants like apple
ibm
and google as i'm sure everybody is
aware of
college is extremely expensive it's
growing more expensive
and we have a post-pandemic world to
look forward to
and actually in the short term that
might manifest in a few
fewer degree holders in the fall of this
year
it seems that undergraduate college
enrollment was down about 2.5 percent
although it does need to be pointed out
that community colleges were the ones
that saw the largest dip in enrollment
so this might not necessarily represent
completely the pool of degree holders
who get into data analysis and data
science but as far as the dynamics of
supply and demand of labor are concerned
we should at least think about this
on one hand we have more alternatives to
traditional education cropping up
we have more and more companies coming
out saying they don't require degrees
and we have the cost of college rising
to absolutely ridiculous levels
then of course there's the current
landscape that's being created by the
pandemic
i'm assuming for the most part that most
colleges
are going to switch back to fully in
person classes as soon as possible
because honestly people paying full
price for
online education is completely
unsustainable
either way you put all these things
together and it is possible that the
supply of
degree holders could decrease in future
years
i don't know that for sure by any means
but it's not impossible
now the flip side to this is pretty
obvious especially when we remember the
scenario
prior to the pandemic people would
always joke that
bachelor's degrees were becoming the new
high school degrees
and that was broadly based on the trend
of how many people were going to college
compared to previous generations
and also you have to take into account
that data science
has been and will continue to get
increasingly complex
so as it requires more and more skills
in order to be successful
it's just natural for a lot of people
one of the first lines of
offense they think about in terms of how
they're going to be able to tackle more
difficult
problems is college hopefully you do get
the impression that while it's certainly
challenging right now to get a data
analyst or data scientist job without a
degree
it's not a hundred percent clear if in
the future it's going to get harder or
easier i lean that it's probably gonna
get
easier but it's anybody's guess now
let's move on to talk about things that
you can actually do and i'm going to
break this down into
skill sets that you should acquire
whether you have a degree or not
resources for building that knowledge
and then some resources for building
some experience
so i've done a video on a study pathway
for data scientists where i break down
what the most important skills are to
learn and in what order to learn them
and the first three are statistics sql
and one of r or python and i think
all those things apply for data analysts
as well
except for them there is one major skill
that i'm leaving out of that list
and that's excel i personally hate excel
with a passion
and if a data science job stresses it a
whole lot that's a major red flag
but at the same time you can't deny that
it is a big part of a lot of different
companies business and analytics stacks
so if you're a data scientist and
especially if you're a data analyst
please know excel you may or may not
love it
but at least for right now it's not
going anywhere
all types of data professionals should
be familiar with statistics to some
capacity and for that it doesn't hurt to
start with some good intro books
i highly recommend the book an
introduction to statistical learning
it's absolutely classic and then it
probably couldn't hurt to pick up the
book
the hundred page machine learning book
either even if machine learning methods
are probably not priority number one for
people just getting started
and while i think a lot of organizations
out there are on to the game that a lot
of people play of loading up on
certifications
especially for people without college
degrees certifications are really going
to come in handy
and that's where coursera comes into
play one course with a pretty solid
structure to it is the statistics within
our specialization
and then there's this other one on
methods and statistics with a social
sciences specialization
now whichever one of these things that
you want to choose is totally up to you
it'll be based on time allocation and
structure
and all types of things like that
obviously i'll have links in the
description
next up of course is sql and so if
you're going anywhere near the data
space
whether that's to be an analyst or a
data scientist
you are going to need to know your
sequel now when i was learning sql for
the first time
i learned it through w3schools.com
and i really love this site because it
breaks things down
into different sections you can try out
different examples
write some code and see what output is
produced i'm also a huge fan of the book
the guru's guide to transact sequel
and if you step through this whole book
and run through all the examples
chances are you're going to run circles
around people at your actual job that
you work with in sql
then of course there's coursera for your
certification purposes too
next you do want to learn either r or
python
and for these you want to learn your
basic syntax and data structures
as well as some things like manipulating
and visualizing data
creating statistical models working with
text
all that fun stuff same types of
resources are going to apply here
meaning a good intro book is going to
give you a great head start
the best intro books for these that i
always recommend
are r for data science by hadley wickham
or python for data analysis by wes
mckinney
but something that i really want to take
a moment to stress with these things
as well as basically with everything
that you learn is that
wherever possible you need to find
opportunities to put what you've learned
into practice and apply it this is
honestly probably the single
best thing that you get out of college
in the first place
it's the different project opportunities
so you do need to find
some type of substitute for that one of
the best resources
on the planet for this is the website
kaggle which has
tons of different competitions and
public data sets
and i can tell you many many data
scientists out there
don't touch it and they still get
employed whether or not they have a
degree
so if you do a real type of analysis
project here
it's something that is guaranteed to
make you stand out
i want to wrap up and just say that to
be perfectly clear
i'm not in the business of
disincentivizing college for anybody
to be perfectly fair for a lot of people
it probably is the single best pathway
towards getting that dream data analyst
or data scientist job
however once again it's simply not an
absolute requirement for everybody
and it's not the path that everybody
wants to take so whether
you don't want to go to college or maybe
you already did but you didn't really
get anything out of it
hopefully now you have some solid food
for thought and you have some practical
next steps that you can take and good
resources
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please consider sharing it
hit the like button if you haven't
already and then i'll see you all in the
not so distant future
until then richard on data